هزه ارضيه تحصد ارواحا وتخلف مناطق منكوبه
في اجزاء واسعه بين تركيا وسوريا ومع كل
كارثه تتنوع طرق رصد قوه الزلازل وتتطور
من بينها الاكثر شهره مقياس ريختر وهو
مقياس كمي يقيس شده الزلازل من خلال تحديد
مقدار ارتفاع اكبر موجه زلزاليه تم رصدها
على مسافه محدده من المصدر الزلزالي
ظهر في ثلاثينيات القرن الماضي مستندا في
تصميمه على الخصائص الجيولوجيه لولايه
كاليفورنيا فقط
كان يقيس شده الزلازل المتوسطه التي
تتراوح بين ثلاث الى سبع درجات الا ان
زلزالا قويا في جنوب كاليفورنيا ادى الى
تطويره ليقيس الزلازل التي تتجاوز سبع
درجات مقياس العزم الزلزالي تكمن دقه
مقياس العزم الزلزلي في مقدار الطاقه
المنطلقه منه عند مص
وقد تم تصميمه ليحل محل عده مقاييس بما
فيها مقياس ريختر ويوفر هذا المقياس قياسا
اكثر تناسقا للزلازل مهما كان عمقها الى
جانب التنبؤ بحوادث تسونامي وغيرها من
المخاطر المرتبطه بالزلزال
مقياس ميركالي ويصف مقياس مركالي معدل
الزلازل من حيث تاثيرها ويستخدم الارقام
العاديه لقياس القوه بينما يستخدم الارقام
الرومانيه للتعبير عن تاثير الزلازل
ويتدرج مقياسه لرصد الزلازل التي تتراوح
قوتها من درجه واحده الى 12 درجه
مقياس وكاله الارصاد الجويه اليابانيه
يقيس حجم الزلازل باستخدام وحده شندو في
اليابان وتايوان فقط ويعتمد على نفس اليه
مقياس مركالي المعدل لكنه يقيس حتى سبع
درجات فقط
وهو تقييم قامت مصلحه المساحه الجيولوجيه
في الولايات المتحده بتطويره عام 2010
للفصل في جدليه ما اذا كان مقياس القوه او
مقياس حجم الزلزال هو الفيصل في مدى
تاثيره وتقوم هذه التكنولوجيا بتقييم مدى
توزيع الهزات وعدد الاشخاص والمجتمعات
المتضرره والوفيات والخسائر المحتمله علي
السمان العربيه